[Musik]
hallo leute wir machen heute eine bayram
torte bayram ist ja das zuckerfest was
nach dem fastenmonat im anschluss drei
tage lang gefeiert wird und da habe ich
hier schon was vorbereitet für unseren
hübschen kuchen nämlich meinen bizkit
boden um ehrlich zu sein wollte ich das
video nicht so in die länge ziehen denn
das basic rezept gibt es ja schon auf
meinem kanal
das ist ganz einfach das rezept in einer
24 cm springform und anschließend für 35
minuten im ofen gebacken und ich kann
euch jetzt schon direkt die zutaten für
die leckere creme zeigen da gehen wir
hier einmal rüber
ich habe in meiner großen schüssel kalte
schlagsahne und doppel ram frischkäse
das ergibt später eine richtig leckere
creme um die fest zu bekommen habe ich
hier seine fest für den geschmack
vanille extrakt und puderzucker
jetzt stehe ich an meiner küchenmaschine
ihr könnt natürlich wie immer auch ein
handrührgerät verwenden das wisst ihr ja
und ich habe das jetzt hier schon mal
beides also doppel ram frischkäse und
schlagsahne in eine rührschüssel gegeben
wir müssen es auch nicht separat
aufschlagen ich fange jetzt anders
langsam zu verrühren und dann immer
höher aufzuschlagen und gibt dann in der
zwischenzeit auch die anderen drei
zutaten rein
[Musik]
so meine lieben die creme ist schön fest
und sie ist weiß ich möchte nämlich eine
weiße kind für die optik natürlich könnt
ihr wenn ihr möchtet da auch marmelade
hinzufügen oder lemon körper irgendetwas
einen hohen so ca zwei bis drei
esslöffel aber wie gesagt bei mir für
die optik bleibt so schön weiß und hier
habe ich jetzt mein tortenboden der es
auch vollständig ausgekühlt der ist
circa fünfeinhalb zentimeter hoch
geworden
ich mach das jetzt so dass sich die
böden zweimal durch teile jeweils
eineinhalb zentimeter hoch aber ihr
könnt ihr auch schauen wird jetzt über
dicke oder lieber dünner
ich mag diese mittel
[Musik]
ich habe mich jetzt dazu entschieden
noch einen vierten boden heraus zu
schneiden als ich hab's insgesamt
dreimal durchgeschnitten dann habe ich
vier dünne böden hier oben die
unebenheiten wie könnt ihr ganz einfach
gerade wegschneiden und später dann
einfach so vernaschen
[Musik]
und jetzt geht's ans schichten also
bisher war alles noch total easy was
jetzt kommt ist auch ganz einfach nehmt
euch jetzt euren lieblings torten
ständer gebt den ersten boden da drauf
und jetzt braucht ihr am besten einen
tortenring damit auch alles schön glatt
wird den cremig jetzt hier einmal
drumherum und beginne dann schon mal die
creme darin zu verteilen
[Musik]
und am besten legt ihr euch nochmal eine
drehbare tortenplatte unter eure
tortenplatte damit ihr das einfach viel
schöner und einfacher verstreichen könnt
ich geh jetz auch immer nur so ein
bisschen creme drauf das jetzt zum
beispiel war nur zwei esslöffel als
nächstes haben wir so ein bisschen pepp
da rein kriegen gebe ich hier
erdbeermarmelade obendrauf
ganz einfach unregelmäßig die dann auch
im anschnitt bestimmt wunderschön aus
und als komplementär dazu ich bin das
passt auch richtig gut zusammen
neben höheren zins kokos jetzt wundert
ihr euch wahrscheinlich warum sie in
ihre kokosflocken so aus ich habe die
ganz einfach im ofen gerüstet auf dem
backblech dauert auch noch ein paar
minuten macht einfach den ofen auf 180
grad ober und unterhitze und nach ein
paar minütchen so richtig schön braun
das gleiche gilt auch in der fettfreien
fahne und die gebe ich jetzt auch
einfach oben drüber und dann könnte
entweder noch ein bisschen creme drauf
klickt aufgeben oder direkt die zweiten
boden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt bin ich ganz oben angekommen eine
liebe ich nehme mir jetzt von meinem
biscuit boden diesen unteren boden und
nehmen den jetzt als deckel obendrauf
denn dann habt ihr auch schon richtig
schönen geraden abschluss und da gebe
ich jetzt nur noch etwas sahne drauf
also sahne creme besser gesagt und dann
fühle ich dass für eine halbe stunde
bevor wir dann den tortenring entfernt
[Musik]
so jetzt ist die torte schön durch
gekühlt und jetzt können auch den
tortenring langsam entfernen
ich nehme jetzt am besten einen
tortenring messer falls ihr das jetzt
nicht da habe dann nimmt eine winkel
palette irgendwas ganz dünn ist damit
ihr den tortenring einmal außen
entfernen könnte annehmen können und
dann geht es weiter
[Musik]
und jetzt nimmt ihr euch eure creme die
ist nämlich noch übrig ich habe mich
extra ein bisschen mehr im vorfeld
zubereitet so steht es dann auch eure
mengenangaben unten in der infobox und
verstreicht die jetzt einfach schön an
den rand schön gehabt
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich hier den rand schön
gesäubert und meine torte ist jetzt
fertig eingestrichen jetzt muss sie für
zwei stunden in den kühlschrank das
ganze könnt ihr natürlich auch am
vorabend vorbereiten aber ihr müsst euch
vorstellen wenngleich die warme
kuvertüre also der glück drauf kommt auf
die sahne creme dann kann es ja
schmelzen und um das zu umgehen müssen
was eben richtig schön kühlen und da
sehen wir uns einfach gleich wieder
ja wir lieben und während die torte
kühlt haben wir schon nicht wir haben
für ziemlich 21.30 noch ein paar
minütchen und sitzt essen gefasst und
machen die torte dann ja relativ spät in
der nacht weiter aber im ramadan ist
sowieso der rhythmus vor durcheinander
oder
[Musik]
so jetzt haben wir gegessen haben uns
gestärkt und getan und jetzt sind weiter
gedreht
unsere tochter ist jetzt wunderbar durch
gekühlt und hier habe ich schon mal
meinen griff vorbereitet das ist ganz
einfach nur freundlich kuvertüre mit
etwas butter die habe ich in der
mikrowelle erwärmt und jetzt würde ich
das so lange bis es sich verbündet und
dann kommt es auf die torte
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich mir hier einiges beiseite
gelegt und schon mal zurecht geschnitten
ich habe hier rosen macarons ein paar
kirschen die habe ich wackler war und
pralinen und ich habe außerdem noch die
restliche creme die übriggeblieben ist
es ist nicht viel aber ein bisschen
wendete übrig haben habe ich mir in
meinen spritzbeutel gefüllt hier oben
die französische stern tolle daran
gemacht und die creme falls es euch
aufgefallen ist die habe ich mir rosa
eingefärbt das müsst ihr nicht machen
das einfach nur für die optik
ihr könnt natürlich auch weiß lassen und
was wir jetzt machen ist mit diesen
ganzen sachen hier einmal auf unsere
torte eine mondsichel form also ihr gibt
es einfach in form einer mondsichel auf
die torte
[Musik]
und wenn ihr dann zufrieden seid mit
eurer mondsichel brauchen wir noch unser
realizing damit schreiben wir nehmen
nicht gleich noch was auf die torte denn
ich finde es fehlt sondern da muss auf
jeden fall als darauf geschrieben werden
so was wie damals am ballermann dass
mubarak würde so lang
ja weil das so lang ist und man müsste
dann richtig klein schreibt schreibe
einfach altenberg und das machen wir
jetzt ich gebe das mal ganz kurz an die
seite vorsichtig und zeigt euch hier und
so zwei zutaten für unser wild icing
und zwar habe ich hier einmal weiß ihr
braucht das ergibt nicht daraus könnt
ihr euch dann rührei machen also war zum
kühlschrank auf und dann macht euch raus
und hier habe ich puderzucker und das
möchte ich jetzt einfach und dann müsst
ihr einfach mal schauen wie viel
puderzucker ihr benötigt das kommt
nämlich immer aufs eis an wie groß das
ist und dann seht ihr das schon an der
konsistenz
[Musik]
wir haben es jetzt auch schon 0 12 meine
augen sehen nicht mehr richtig
aber was tut man nicht alles für eine
gelungene torte
wir zeigen euch mal die konsistent dem
so langsam runter fließen und dann ist
es genau richtig und ich mach das jetzt
so ihr könnt jetzt entweder einen
spritzbeutel nehmen eine ganz kleine
loch telefone dran machen was ich aber
einfacher findet beim schreiben sind
diese spritzten aus papier wie zeige ich
euch jetzt dafür musste aber einmal
aufschieben herankommen
bist du darauf ich tue und zwar
schneidet ihr euch so ein stück
backpapier zurecht und dann nehmen wir
das hier freuen dass ein und die mich zu
achten dass es vorne zoos und mich offen
also ist klingt jetzt kommt die zeit als
es ist dann könnt ihr das hier oben
nämlich rein klicken dann ist das schön
fixiert und kann auch nichts mehr schief
gehen und jetzt finde ich da meine
leistung ein
[Musik]
so und jetzt meine lieblings
ich dachte mir so kann man das besser
weil die tour de torture so hoch und
jetzt habe ich ja hier mein mäuschen
drin und ich schreibe ich ja etwas drauf
und das kann ich am besten wenn ich von
oben drauf guckt also schnappt ihr euch
auch am besten ein hocker stellt euch
drauf und dann geht es dann aber erst
nur einen versuch
also wenn es ist cool sie wird dann kann
man nichts machen oder eine schwester
und ihr müsst darauf achten dass hier
vorne die spitze abgeschnitten wird
musste ich jetzt nicht machen dann wie
war das jetzt schon offen
das gucke ich dann immer noch das offen
ist dann mache ich hier so ein versuch
weiß nicht ob man sitzt weiß auf weiß
sehen kann über ok und ansonsten einfach
eine spitze von abschneiden
los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ich finde schon richtig schön und
richtig gelungen jetzt fehlten meiner
meinung nach nur noch der abschluss hier
unten da fehlt mir noch so ein bisschen
was und dann nehme ich jetzt ganz
einfach pistazien die habe ich jetzt
hier schon mal so ein bisschen klein
gehackt und die gebe ich wirklich nur so
ganz leicht also ich knall jetzt nicht
mehr komplett dran aber so mit ein
bisschen abstand gebe ich dir jetzt an
den unteren rand
[Musik]
ja meine lieben das war es mit der torte
sie hält sich jetzt gekühlt drei tage
lang wir können es also locker einen tag
vorher vorbereiten dann im kühlschrank
lagern
ich finde sie nicht nur wunderschön ich
liebe ja so eine art orten total vom
aussehen her
aber sie ist auch im geschmack richtig
gut und punktet bei jedem ihr trefft
euch doch bestimmt mit der familie
und dann gibt es immer verschiedene
geschmäcker in der familie aber bei der
torte macht ihr so wie ich denke alles
richtig haben sie hat zum beispiel auch
eine große familie meine familie ist
mittelgroß aber wenn alle beisammen
kommen ist das eine torte die jeder
gerne mag ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz
viel spaß im nachbacken schaut unten in
die infobox da habe ich euch alle
genauen mengenangaben reingeschrieben
macht euch ein screenshot einkaufen
gehen und nach machen und dann markierte
mich im besten falle auf instagram und
facebook mit dem hashtag kies kitchen
ja und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten video ganze nur noch was gute
nacht
[Musik]